genre dans notre séquence ping-pong je
reçois bernard violet pour son ouvrage
de 9 la franchit il va répondre à une
critique de paul wermus de france soir
bonsoir
non je vous présente vous êtes
journaliste cet ouvrage à votre couple
un deuxième hausse est de 21 tout
augmente
voilà qu'elle se soit des les ouvrages
d'investigation vous avez craqué sur la
fin du verbe barca sur papon sur les
services secrets du temps de mitterrand
et vous êtes un spécialiste des
biographies et des biographies non
autorisées vous appelez plus tôt vous ça
des bio vérité c'est ça je préfère
effectivement alors quelles ont été vos
votre tableau de chasse alors en bio non
autorisées non justement cdcc des jolies
ce qu'ils font pas bien leur travail à
savoir qu'effectivement sur une
demi-douzaine de biographie
quand on construit certains c'est un
héros ont accepté de collaborer d'autres
non parmi ceux qui ont accepté
johnny hallyday qui quand même pas le
dernier rock est revenue l'abbé pierre
et puis un autre proche de françois
mitterrand l'ami d'un ami banquier de
françois mitterrand que ceux qui
refusent en général le refus soit parce
que ça rende pas dans leurs plans médias
il faut faire une fête quand même parce
que monsieur picholine nous sommes pas
dans une république bananière en france
que je sache que l'expression est libre
est donc que des personnages publics et
des chats ni aux questions ni au regard
alors il est indiqué un joli bandeau
rouge les mystères d'une star est ce que
réellement vous révéler les mystères
dans votre biographie ou bien est ce que
c'est une des ses biographies qui fait
un gros roulement de tambour et enfin à
l'intérieur on trouve pas encore écouté
vu les premiers articles de presse qui
ont été publiés vue travail que j'ai
fourni effectivement non il ya pas mal
de révélations bon en même temps vous
savez les mystères des stars sont
souvent que des amas de petits secrets
quelqu'un croit sur une avouables alors
qu'une fois que les livres en public -
ben c'est très sain parce que au
contraire je trouve ça leur apporte une
part d'humanité beaucoup de buts
beaucoup plus passionnant que ces images
des comptes classe c à vous roulez moins
franchement vous avez voulu prendre
catherine demain plus humaine dans les
90 dans cet ouvrage la bri la passion il
ya partout il ya des patrons juifs anti
sympathie que c'est pas que mon fils
c'est parce que c'est un personnage pas
franchement sympathique c'est tout on va
voir ce qu'il en est du contenu c'est un
ouvrage qui est partagé en quatre
parties celle et captant de l'avis de
catherine deneuve paul wermus à lui
votre ouvrage il n'est pas très
convaincu alors voyons un peu quels sont
ces arguments et voyons ce que vous avez
lui répond présente l'état fait et cette
fois-ci vous consacrez un véritable pavé
à catherine deneuve 477 pages pour dire
quoi
je me demande pas grand chose ce qui
vous déteste ceux qui vouent jalouse
disent que vous faites les poubelles
voilà ça c'est pas gentil ça c'est pas
franchement la critique argumentée
j'aurais pu attendre à en recevoir
cela étant bros poubelles effectivement
les poubelles pour moi on était les
archives nationales de france
les archives historiques la cinémathèque
de nombreux témoins dont certains grands
noms du cinéma
benoît jacquot des grands critiques
peut-être le plus grand critique
français du cinéma le patron des cahiers
du cinéma jean michel frodon des acteurs
marthe villalonga galabru qui était
atteint
bon je pense pas que ça se fera quand
même des gens que je suis allé chercher
dans les poubelles
continuons à l'entrée on continue dans
le billet d'humeur mon cher paul bert
certes vous êtes un provocateur
professionnel bernard violet mais ça ne
suffit pas honnête ni tom wolfe ni
pierre jean rémy ni même henri jean
servat ce qui nous manque dans ce livre
c'est le style c'est l'inspiration leur
manège que le panache bon alors le
romanesque mais panache lecteurs qu'ils
jugeront je crois que mes lecteurs pour
l'instant soient ses nombreux je suis
quand même 30e des meilleures ventes
cette semaine l'express
deuxième chose romanesque effectivement
moi je suis et journaliste plutôt
sérieux méthodique rigoureux dans les
faits le roman non je ne fais pas des
fictions
cela étant je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
passages qui sont magnifiques soient
carrière de catherine deneuve ou sa vie
de jeune fille je petite bourgeoise du
16e se transforme en véritable conte de
fées
donc il ya aussi une part du rêve dans
la vie même de catherine deneuve
alors on le veut ce souffle la grâce la
vert et peut-être et surtout l'
enthousiasme
oui donc la pâte violer la pâte ciolek
est ce que c'est la pente est rude je
parle pour tous un peu sont pas billet
d'humeur mais en même temps lors du sap
si justement
trois ans de travail ça c'est pas
seulement un contrat avec un éditeur
il commence comment comment alors
sérieusement dans le monde dans le
métier est ce qu est ce qu on appelle un
tueur à gages en vous mais un contrat
sur une personnalité on nous dit bernard
aller faut y aller
viala c'est un peu ça dans une chose que
je propose quelques fois des sujets
l'europe thématique des grandes
thématiques sur les réseaux pasqua sur
des affaires qui m'intéresse et me dire
c'est que les sources de procès qui
s'arrêtera disant que depuis son
best-seller de long qui est vendu à plus
de cent mille exemplaires 150000 toutes
éditions confondues
bon on m'a enfermée un peu de ce genre
de la biographie bon ensuite c'est une
question de négociations avec l'éditeur
sur même nom une liste de personnalités
que je leur suggère un outsider
oui ça oui bond de 9 flammarion a été
quand même couru 1 pour se lancer dans
ce projet sachant connaissons les
ardeurs procédurière de belle de jour
alors envers les ardeurs procédure est
alors au chapitre des révélations je
reste totalement sur ma faim vous croyez
casser le mythe de 9 ans nous apprennent
alors si c'est important parce qu'on me
l'a reproché victimes à y avait des
journaux ont titré il casse les mythes
de neuf mois je pense pas je pense que
finalement on
dévoilant quelques fois certains
mystères c'était une faiblesse d'une
trahison celle contre vérités
contradiction quand je dis franchement
que je le rapport plutôt une part
d'humanité bien peu plus bien plus
fascinante que ces images du cône de
glace 1 que la presse se colporte depuis
des décennies alors et puis franchement
entre nous soit dit daniel pauly vous
qui êtes un admirateur un défi est
inconditionnel de 2,9
vous ne pensez pas que le jour il ya
trois quatre ans lorsqu'on a appris que
catherine deneuve s'était fait remettre
une enveloppe de 30000 euros dans des
toilettes
l'hôtel de luxe d'accord les toilettes
franchement la lie vous pour vous vous
devez pas utiliser quelque part que la
le monde et écorné le mais qu'est ce qui
vous a distillé dans lequel se fasse
prendre en 30 parce que franchement les
artistes faisant payer dans des
enveloppes
ça existe nourris et chez les mêmes pas
illégal non sauf ce qui est illégal
c'est quand ce n'est pas déclarée au
fisc ne sera pas être fixé il s'est
adapté à les toilettes qui vous ont
cherché à rejoindre au garçon à bachy
bôbo c'était un modèle gt la beauté à
cannes la plus belle femme du monde on a
dit qu elle donnait des rôles soit la
plus belle femme du monde virtuel
quand on se fait remettre de l'argent de
façon clinique comme ça franchement là
le mythique homme était connu et 7 euros
fait si l'ue mettait de navettes et
connaissent et par de nouvelles même nom
que son père maurice dorléac avait
fricoté avec l'occupant neige alors
fricoter bon j'étais restée à
l'intérieur déjà l'histoire c'est pas
uniquement à fricoter je veux dire que
de 1940 à 1944 début à la fin de la
guerre le papa dans les actes
effectivement collaboré à radio paris il
paraît donc pour l'occupant nazi en
faisant rémunérer avec des émissions
plutôt google mais également quelques
émissions à tendance prévient dit lui
même dans des documents je trouve aux
archives nationales
deuxième chose il a quand même figurer
dans deux courts métrages de propagande
pour la milice française
mais quel rapport avec catherine
d'honneur alors ce qui est important
c'est que à mon avis c'est un des
secrets de catherine deneuve qui a été
dure à avaler pour la gamine bon et
qu'elle a très bien avaler quand
j'explique dans le bouquin elle a pris
des positions complètement l'opposé de
son père politiquement parlant tout prix
tout était progressiste a on peut dire
d'autre part elle a tourné le dernier
trop à la voilà vous avez compris c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant pour moi le
truffaut dans lequel elle joue les
spéciales de ce rallye c'est son secret
de famille en espérant l'écriture de
delhi metro ce chef-d'oeuvre
donc d'où l'intérêt de raconter ce type
il alors qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important dans l'image de 9 quel effet
le dernier métro que son père était
collabos on ne choisit pas ses parents
tu devrais je dire je juge pas bon je
rapporte des faits et qui explique un
peu celle et les ressorts de ce
personnage des ressorts d'ultérieures
exceptionnel dans ce sens que ensuite à
travers son père c'est tout un relation
des relations amicales qui vont aider la
carrière non seulement de catherine des
défenseurs doléac des relations amicales
nouées pendant l'occupation ou permis à
katrina françois si vous voulez d'avoir
un début de carrière plutôt aisée par
rapport à d'autres acteurs ou d'objets
de ce côté là que vous attendez à voir
un procès non pas du tout parce que je
pense que le seul projet qu'on peut me
faire si vous êtes être la mémoire d'un
mort là je parle d'histoire bon je pense
pas que la justice la suivra sur ce
terrain là on écoute la voix d'avis
alors alors prenez un risque en misant
sur sa maison avec janouille c'est ça
attention je suis prudent revoilà dans
le livre effectivement
johnny johnny quand même ce que j'ai
fait une biologie avec ses
collaborations jeudi par les deux
catherine deneuve avec laquelle il a
tourné à 61 parisiens et des parisiennes
et qui était le début
m'at-il dit d'une grande passion et
mathilde est encore là même la plus
grande passion de sa vie
bon alors évidemment on était avec signe
pourtant l'amour est ensuite vont cesser
une relation une passion que revanche
que fut deuxième a toujours nié bon donc
non moins un mort sur cette relation est
ce que vous savez des choses que vous
n'avez pas dit oui oui là c'est que je
ne vais pas dire parce qu'en france on
peut pas dire certaines choses sans être
poursuivi pour atteinte à la vie privée
etc etc
enfin sur son parcours professionnel
vous nous racontez vous nous décrivez
bernard violet que des idées reçues des
évidences des banalités des lieux
communs des platitudes et poncifs vous
êtes passé à côté d'un grand livre
qu'est ce que ces textes grand livre l
angoisse de l'âge c'était le désamour du
public
c'était lâche là les hameaux du public
alors là il se plaint pas qu il n'a pas
lu les traces que justement la dernière
partie était utile et la fuite du temps
et du temps ci comme en 2009 a accepté
très mal évidemment le temps qui passe
mais ici on voit ce qu'ils touchent tous
oui absolument
messieurs ses plus rudes et attisé parce
que c'est la solitude le regard des
autres voilà ce qui aurait ce qu'on
aurait aimé lire de vous en faites vous
n'avez pas eu l'inspiration
en vérité cette biographie à la fois
raté ap avec votre prochaine biographie
celle qui sera consacrée à jamel
debbouze voilà merci pour juger si c'est
vrai pour jamel debbouze il s'agit
d'autoriser une
en attendant écoutez je les contacte et
conjugue sollicite tous je dirais un nom
à peu près avant la sortie du bouquin
pour l'instant il n'a pas dit non donc
j'espère bon en tout cas là on parlait
avec avec vous bernard violet et paul
wermus de 2,9 l'affranchi une
conversation libre et france est bien
évidemment comme d'habitude
j'engage chacun à se faire une idée en
lisant va votre livre et puis on voit un
vide pour jamel debbouze
merci
[Musique]